hey so I'm going to talk about data
visualization with data visualization
with UGS it's not really a talk about
data visualization it's more talk about
UJS it's just quite a nice way of
introducing it so my name is Callum I'm
the lead front-end developer at a
company called Sam nose we do a lot of
data visualization and we use view into
the talk I've also written a book on
view called VG s up and running which if
you like the talk you should check it
out so I'm going to start talk with a a
couple questions who's use view before
here
three people gray I speaking to the
right people and who knows what SVG is
most of you cool who's written SVG from
scratch using using code go to view I'm
definitely talking to the right people
so SVG it's an XML based vector image
format it's an open standard by the w3c
it's been around since 1999 basically
lets you write images using code instead
of bitmaps loads of pixels so this image
on screen this is a PNG so if we zoom in
those it's pretty blurry where's the
next one it took a while I don't know
what happened there the next one this
one's the SVD one so if we zoom in we
can see it's like nice and crisp for
those of you haven't seen it before by
the way this is the view logo and in
code form this is the V logo so it's
pretty small it it's it sends the
browser really quickly and it's really
easy to play with so next let's look at
some let's look at some view so how many
of you used angular before quite a few
of you or really any templating language
should be fairly familiar with this
syntax so at the top left we've got our
H we've got our template I'm at the top
right we've got our JavaScript so what
this is doing is it's looping through so
on the right we're defining chart data
which is an array of data it's an array
of numbers and on the Left we're using
our v4 directive
to lick through the array it creates a
new paragraph element for every single
item in the array and then inside we're
using interpolation to say we want to
output the value in every paragraph
element so you can see here we've got
we've got our paragraph elements output
by view so next let's leave you alone
for a bit and go look at SVG so this
this is SVG it's XML you can put it in
your you can put it in your documents
directly you don't have to lose it as a
dot SVG image and here we just got a
black rectangle we've defined our SVG
element and inside we've got our rect
element which is a rectangle so we've
given it a width and a height and an x
and a y position and it's just a black
black rectangle like you can see on the
bottom but that's a bit boring so let's
make it a nice orange beige color okay
so so here we just added a fill
actually I was giving it a color so
let's go back to view so here we've got
the width and the height and the X on
the way we just hard-coded that but
let's say we want to get that from our
Java Script so here we've just wrapped a
tweet so we go back to this similar
example as before we've got our view
which is saying I can't want to want to
work on the chart element which in this
case is the SVG and we've defined our
width by x and y using numbers in the
data attribute in the data property so
what we're doing now is we're using the
V bind directive to say we want to bind
the width and the height and the X and
the y positions to the value from the
object so it's basically the exact same
it's the exact same rectangle but
powered using JavaScript which prolly
isn't a great idea if you just want a
rectangle on the page don't use
JavaScript but if you want to if you
want to make something more interactive
or more powerful then this is definitely
the way to do it so this is the V bind
directive it might it looks a bit wordy
to write V bind every time
they've given us a little shortcut you
can just not right V bind you can start
with a colon and this does the same
thing so here we've still got width is
width and then we're getting 200 from
there from the data object so that's
that's a rectangle but so let's go back
to V for the directive we looked at
before and start making a little bar
trap so there's a few new things on this
slide I'm going to talk them through one
by one so first there's the the G
element the G element in SVG is the it's
kind of like the equivalent of div in
HTML it doesn't really do anything but
you can put stuff inside it so so we're
using v4 on the G element so it's
outputting the G element a few times
each one of them has a rectangle and a
text element in and we also we can't use
x and y on G elements we have to use
transforms but it's it's it's a similar
idea so it's being translated zero zero
pixels across and then down I times 40
so I if you look back at the visa vie
for statement is the index of that array
element so basically every single one
has been moved down another 40 pixels
and we're getting a load of rectangles
below each other we've also introduced a
new text element it's just how you make
text in SVG pretty simple that one so we
haven't mm cool so next sorry
so next I'm let's let's let's program
the width because previously we just had
previously of all the same way it's not
looking like a bar chart yet so to make
the width we're going to just we're
going to make it so we're going to so
you don't just you can't just in V bind
you don't just use variables you can
also put JavaScript statements so here
we're doing some maths where we're
taking 500 pixels which we're going to
say the max width is
20 foot and then we're going to say the
max number of the chart data is 20 so
basically we're working out the width as
a proportion of the maximum number so
we've just given it a width but this
this is it's getting a bit wordy in the
template now so let's talk about let's
talk more about the view object so right
now we just looked at how you can get
data from the objects into the template
but if you do that for everything it'll
your template won't be very nice and so
so there's there's ways say on the
object and the view objects so we've
seen so far is we've seen the L property
which says what we want to work on and
we seen the data property which says
what data we want to play and let's look
at a way of adding some more stuff so so
let's look at methods first so here
remember the last slide we put 500
divided by 20 x value in the template
but here we've moved it to a method so
in the template now instead of doing the
math we're just calling bar width valley
which is being passed into the method to
calculate in the valley it's passing it
back to the template and outputting
exactly the same thing to the page but
yep so that's the best methods now let's
look at computer properties so I've hard
coded the 20 there but as the maximum
value of chart data but we don't we
could make another method so we're
passing chart data and work out the
maximum value pull it back in but
instead there's a better way to do it
we've got computed properties and so
computer properties can you see that at
the back cool computer properties are
kind of like halfway between methods and
the data so the data we access it can't
we can't really it doesn't change based
on the values of other stuff and methods
are from there basically functions we
call them every time they evaluate every
single time computer properties are
halfway between the two we access them
as if they're properties of the data
object but they're executed as functions
here you can see in the template I say
so here we can see we're calling the
method I'm gonna go back a step because
I didn't explain this so so here we've
got this chart width so this doc chart
width it's referring to the chart width
from the data objects so everything you
could access using chart width in the
template you can access using this chart
with anywhere else in the view object
which is like a nice way of calling
methods and computer properties from
each other so here in in the in the
method I've hard coded I've added the
the width and the height into the data
object so that so that we can so they
now - ha create that value every time
and so also so then yeah let's go back
to computer property so here we've got
the computes property which we call just
the same as if it's a data value but
then it executes something to work out
the value so we can see it's looking at
our array of numbers and it's working
out the maximum value returning that the
the advantage of so methods and computer
properties look pretty similar but they
hit behave quite differently so here's
like an illustration of how it yeah so
that's just you can see the top one is a
function the bottom one behaves as if
it's just a property of the data object
but in addition to the syntax difference
they also behave differently so you can
demonstrate this by calling them
multiple times so methods every time you
call them in a template it'll evaluate
it'll evaluate it so it'll call the
method three times but if you every time
you call a computed property unless the
original unless one of the valleys in it
has changed they'll only be called once
and so here we can see that the the
method has been called three times that
the computes property is any being
called once and then the value is being
cashed
so I not just recovered from a cold so
my mouth quite right I'm caught so next
next um
so am i speaking neck - wrong it threw
me a second
what's changed on this slide I think I
accidentally put the same slide in twice
yeah anyway so it's pretty hit not not
yet don't like it's a it's a cool so I
if I've got time there's a couple more
things that I couldn't really show in
keynote because they're more interactive
things so I'll just bring up copán
caught the first thing I wanted to show
is events so the events in tax in view
is quite nice hidsim so I'm alright so
what I'm doing here is we've had an
event so it uses the V on directive
which we're passing click to V on as an
argument so now when we click on this it
calls the handle click method and in the
handle click method it's just updating
the chart data with some random data
generated here so we can see when we
click it that it changes and this this
demonstrates something really nice in
view in that it's everything is reactive
so we're changing we're changing the
chart data which in turn is causing the
bar whit to update and views handling
all this internally when it's not like
reacts we're um we're we're changing
this where we're making a new state
we're mutating the state in view it's
like a very fundamental difference team
react and view react you create a new
object you don't mutate the old object
whereas V you make you take the old
object it's it's a took me a while to
get used to you but it's actually really
nice now and it means that just when you
change one thing everything changes
automatically it's really nice so also V
on is also another quite used thing so
this one has a shortcut as well we can
just delete that replace it with an and
with an @ sign and it still works cool
and the other quick time I don't think
I've got time to fully explain it but
you can also animate things really
nicely with you which is another really
big difference doing buin react and that
ignore that I'll fix that in a second
and view is really so in reacts I
haven't used react in a couple years so
I might be explaining this one
it in react something has a state and
it's got a state and then it's got
another state and there's no concept of
being between states from what I
remember and I've been told and but
where with view that it's a lot easier
to transition between stuff I don't
think I've got time to explain it freely
I just wanted to show you because it's
really nice and a good example and what
I will show you though is how to fix
this
so with view similar to most template
engines we've got filters so you can see
we've got a filter here we pass it so
call it round we pass it a number it
rounds it
and now we get a lot to me that
animation down the last one cool and
I'll just go back to my slides but that
is the end of the talk
you